joining us now former deputy independent
Council and former assistant U.S
attorney Saul weisenberg all right Saul
well late tonight Trump's attorneys
filed a response in that D.C case that
reads in part the government seeks to
restrict First Amendment rights worse it
does so against this administration's
primary political opponent during an
election season in which the
administration prominent party members
and media allies have campaigned on the
indictment and proliferated its false
allegations
um your response tonight to that
I haven't seen that filing yet but I
think that former president Trump's
attorneys are going to have a lot more
success and get a lot fairer hearing
from the federal court in the southern
district of Florida than they've and
they've gotten so far in in D.C
well Saul the issue about
president Trump not being able to
respond in social media for instance and
you know he's always you know his
comments on social media can be over the
top you know I'm coming for you on that
particular issue what's your take
because there are civil Libertarians out
there say well that's restricting First
Amendment speech that are others are
saying well that could be a comment
about you know other potential Witnesses
or he could be sending a signal that
would be tampering with the proceeding
what's your take
well there is an inherent conflict
between the kind of gag orders and and
restrictions on the speech of defendants
and defense attorneys and the normal
First Amendment uh rights that we have
and unfortunately the case law set by
the Supreme Court is is unclear all on
this they decided on a case-by-case
basis and most districts have a rule
that says you can't make a statement a
defendant no party can make a statement
that might impact the administration of
justice and that's very that's very
loosey-goosey and he's going to have to
be careful about what he says on social
media and we're likely to see some kind
of a ruling very soon from Judge chutkin
in D.C and um and so stand by because
she accelerated the response time you
know normally Trump's attorneys would
have had a lot more time and they didn't
have it here well Saul judge chutkin
versus judge Cannon those are two
different you know perspectives on
federal law clearly and we're going to
see we're going to get a lesson in you
know different approaches to judicial
interpretation are we not
absolutely absolutely it looks that way
and expect judge Cannon to be uh
continue to be attacked by by some of
the people you showed earlier today
they're already talking about uh oh
we're gonna have to move to recuse her
but really these Federal prosecutors in
most cases including most high-profile
political cases are used to getting
whatever they want from federal judges
because the way the federal system is
heavily slanted in favor of the
prosecution and this judge in the
southern district of Florida judge
Cannon is saying wait a minute explain
yourself you don't automatically get to
put things under seal you haven't made a
strong enough showing and and so she's
also said wait a minute I want an
explanation for why you're using the DC
grand jury
for post-indictment matters in Florida
so there are two things it's it's that
she's interested in here number number
one you brought this case in the
southern district of Florida why are you
using the D.C grand jury related to that
case number two once you indict a case
the law says you're not allowed to use
the grand jury use a grand jury to
gather evidence for trial now there's a
major exception to that that exception
is if the prosecutor says well wait
we're looking at further crimes we might
file a superseding indictment but judge
Cannon is saying I want a public
explanation if it's okay
if you say it's okay to use the DC grand
jury to to gather evidence tell us why
on the record in a way they're very
different cases but in a way it's like
uh the judge did in the hunter Biden
case in Delaware saying wait wait a
minute I want this clear on the record
so she might end up letting Jack Smith
do what he wants to do but she's going
to make him articulate the reason why
it's interesting that in these political
cases citizens learn about stuff that
regular I've been doing Federal
white-collar criminal defense for 23
years stuff that regular defendants have
to put up with all the time and citizens
now see how the system really works and
how it's slanted against defendants all
right Saul thank you so much great to
see you tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else